So um
uh well
since we have small room people and we
have a few people online uh let's get
people close to each other so we can
talk more intimately and I think today
let's let's just I know I'll share a lot
of ideas some idea about the visual
analytics and uh by visual analytics and
but I also wanted to hear from you. What
do you think? What's your interest? Yes.
Um I want to just do a quick survey
like it's supposed to be presentation uh
but there's I can't present right now
so just that's okay. So uh are you guys
all working with the graph? I know he's
he's he's making graph databases
but [laughter]
is from graph
right outside. It's a really exciting
part. So, are you guys all like familiar
with graph using graph in day out? Yeah.
Oh, that's um let's see. And uh are you
guys using RDF? RDF. Yeah. LPG.
Yeah. That's good. Yeah. How many people
use 4J?
We used to use
>> box.
What is that?
>> It's also a database but it's triple
>> triple
inter.
>> Oh, interesting.
Yeah, cool. Um
Oh, here. So
well
what kind of visualization tools you
guys use like
Python network access and do you build
your own like visualization layers using
JavaScript D3 or what what what kind of
tool you use? So we used to use
>> Yeah. But now we are using
connecting.
>> Yeah.
But we are still not there yet.
>> So it's on.
>> Yeah. PowerBI. That's interesting.
PowerBI. I would love to hear more about
you doing the graph and PowerBI. It's
very interesting. Yes. Um
>> yeah,
view
the name of it.
>> We can
have a presentation.
>> Okay. I think because of the sh
>> Okay.
>> Unfortunately.
>> Uh one question maybe from my personal
interest is how many do you guys like
practice like any sort of art form?
What kind of art? Guitar music.
>> Oh nice.
I I used to play guitar too but all
trainer myself realized that guitar is
when I realized that you got to take the
classes as for training otherwise you
have a consistency. Yeah, there's a a
lot of structural thing in the music and
and visualization that really connect
you guys.
>> My first career was design
>> design. Yeah. Then move on to computer
animation business.
>> Yeah. Design on computer design.
>> Yes. And you guys any sort of painting
drawing.
>> Yeah. And so uh I actually um started
dancing when I was doing posttock in in
Berkeley and um and found out a lot of
inspirations from uh dance choreography
and visualization how we how we like how
I wouldn't see like creating names of
things but me how we perceive
information perceive as like really a
lot of things that actually connected.
Um, so let's see where I can go. Um,
so this was supposed to be a handsome uh
class and but I noticed that you guys
don't really have a computer with you.
Uh,
>> yeah. But um it's okay. Like if you want
to follow through and try something on
your own, you can. If you don't, it's
it's fine. I just just see what I'm
doing. Yeah. Yeah.
So this is this is a data set that u
uh I have a few data set in there use as
example to to illustrate some ideas
introduced today.
So, so really today's mostly I want to
share uh my own past experience and and
own research on how the visual works.
What is the what is the need? what kind
of tool we need to build to perform
visual analys
so
what what's your interest in getting out
from this
session I'm curious
>> yeah for me it's uh because I'm very
technical
>> so I work in large enterprise
And we try to
no one cares
ideally.
>> Yeah.
>> My interest.
alternatives
to knowledge.
>> Something
very
mysterious.
>> Yeah. How about you guys? Anybody want
to share?
>> We have a visualization. visualization
capability within software
um which is
very powerful at the moment.
We can show our clients
>> within the business itself
visualizations
impact. [clears throat]
>> Yeah.
>> To the client.
>> Yeah. for for me
broader
>> yeah a broader example
choice in data visualization
>> yeah
is out there
>> I see
marketing aspect being able to sell
ideas so you need something that
attention looks good but also has that
meaning ask questions
stories and stuff you can show every
significant
>> right and
>> for me it's like I started my career as
a data analytics
>> and I've been doing data analysis for
almost two years now and I was always
missing a part where how do you get this
to end user Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> As you said, it already has that. Yes.
For certain people who need to show it
as visualized as possible so that they
can understand that okay
looks like at least uh so for me it's
like to understand how it could be done
>> right
>> what all the needed.
>> Yeah. How easy does
>> right
that's great. Yeah. So I also notic
people online
um really apologize I'm not able to um
like really like share the attention
because it's very interactive. Uh so um
so here's the uh the data set that I I
put together like some some sample data
can use it be interesting follow along
try something
yeah
just so I want to just show a quick
video so the mic we're having trouble
with your Oh
>> okay
turn that one off and we'll just use the
handheld
That sounds better.
So
this is pretty much one of the first
visualization of data that I made a
while ago
that actually
so hearing you guys like you very
interested in how to transend in a most
effective way. Um so
when we talk about the visualization of
graph data I think there's a there's a
few things one is what you can present
how you can using visualization to this
is strange myself really strange
is it possible to just mute the sound of
people this is only Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Uh, okay. Can you just make sure
the online people can hear?
>> Yeah. Okay, I'm talking. Yeah. Okay,
that's good. Yeah, much better.
So, so when we come to visualization,
there's um there's a few things. There's
the first is effective visualization. Um
the effective visualization has has in
my in my in my opinion has two things.
One is to uh illustrate the information
you want you want to present. Two is to
discover the things that you not yet um
know what sometime you don't even have
like I think Einstein said that right
like if I have one hour to to answer the
most answer most important question uh I
spend like 55 minutes or something to
figure out what question to ask. I think
that's that's from my experience is very
often figure out the question to ask is
is like the hardest once you have the
question once you know what question to
ask you can formulate strategy to get
answer and or in this case visualize
effectively but figure out what to ask
what question even to to dig into it
that usually takes quite a few
iterations. So hence I think the the
visualization is important in both
seeing what's coming out but also to
guide you towards like iterative process
of asking questions discover new
questions ask next questions and the
faster you can cut through the loop uh
the more effective analytics workflow uh
will be so I want to just quickly just
show a example that I have let's
Okay.
So,
okay. Online is not working.
This part is interesting. Check this
out.
So, do do you guys notice the
the uh different industries graph?
Maybe I play that again. Let's see.
Yeah, this is the part
that's healthare.
So when we first
when you first look at the data, so the
data is collected from the uh the blocks
on the blocks, right?
It's like a Dropbox but more targeting
enterprise space. It's an enterprise
space of a like a file sharing like a
collaboration platform. So we work with
them to to analyze the data collected on
their platform which is generating
visualization. Um
so um they did a lot of work on
generating analytics like statistics
like uh the like the degree of
connections like uh the how many average
average like sharing activities like
collaboration activities has done like
the the frequency the distribution of
the time they did a lot of that
but there's certain certain
characteristic it's really difficult to
see um from those numbers um it's really
like how overall the collaboration
happens in the organization So when we
visualize the data in this way and you
can actually see very clearly that look
at the health care health care is almost
like living or organism it's quite
distributed like uh but in each each hub
there's in collaborations but then
there's among them among many hubs
there's a different kind of
visualization different kind of like
loose connections
um And the finance space it's um um
this is actually already make it a
little bit random but if you look at it
it's very centralized.
There's a there's a clear hierarchy of
how information gets distributed from
one or two people in the center go to
the next layer like only ring to the
next next layer. There's very little
interconnections. uh this
and then you go look at the uh software
industry. Software industry is also is
very interesting in the sense that
there's you can't you can you cannot
discover hierarchy in the software
industry. It's communication is very
random. It's everybody talk to
everybody. So that's really uh
interesting thing like software industry
like in in finance industry you need
this kind of hierarchical
maintain order. So something happens you
know who to talk to how to solve it. In
software industry there's a lot on like
a impromptu conversation
happen. Um and
like uh there's a we look into many
different industries and we notice a lot
of patterns is that it's very difficult
to to to give a name but you can see the
clear difference and the next question
really is how do you measure that those
difference like without looking at the
patents it's actually quite difficult to
construct matrix. So we can can we can
actually see the difference in the uh uh
in the different industry. Um so that
project we originally want to drive
deeper like looking for comparative like
finding a set companies in each industry
doing comparative study. Uh in the end
um because of the IFC issues and other
issues we decide not to go forward with
that. So,
and
so you guys are in the LPJ like RDF
space. Uh I'm more in the uh labor
property graph space. Um
when it come to visualization so so in
fact in early days we developed the
software for for RDF to visualize RDF
information. uh we found the challenge
is that uh RDF in RDF is very break down
to the detail a lot of details it's
really great for semantic reasoning
really great for like set up the rules
and inference but when it come to
visualization we found it very
challenging
and so in the end we we like I found out
that LPG is easier information to for
the visualization purpose. I'm still
trying to figure out a way to uh convert
RDF data into a form that's easier to
visualize.
We should talk about if you guys have
any ideas, I really love to talk to you
about it. So, so here's like a lot of
database like that happened over the
over years like Neo 4j came out like
2007 I believe.
um multipart title graph um like later
and lately there's a couple database
the kuzu they're talking the next four
invalid database um and on one one end
spectrum uh that make you don't need to
no more no need to server and on the
device there's a google
that I think they gonna they just
released. It's a it's a cloud database.
So it's like graph database is really
expanding uh from like a road from the
like a data lake on the one end to
embedded on the other end and
performance is also improving
drastically from the Neo 4j to like
tiger pip nap that performance really
has improved a lot over the time. Yeah.
And then I also look at the
visualization toolings. Uh roughly kind
of separate from the library approach to
the application approach.
On the one end you have a network X3 C.
JS it's all like library approach. uh
on the on the other hand like the bloom
in curious and graphics is like that's
we make this on as a more application
project and then you have something I
see is more geared towards a uh
exploration
they use graph to explore to a solution
building I use graph for application
so so that is like I know I'm Leaving
something out here, but this is the
things I most familiar with.
Well, um what attract me to the graph is
like a how intuitive it is. It really
mir mirrors how how we think about
things. [clears throat]
So it's it's a given that um graph uh is
the really helps with to help us
reasoning
but there's a
but if you think about it um I actually
did look look up research and we our
brain can only hold
roughly seven piece of information at a
time
and so
if a if a graph
>> [clears throat]
>> So one one challenging thing for us is
visualizing graph is the number of
elements on the screen right if you have
a few elements on the graph on the
screen with the connections it's amazing
it's great it makes sense we immediately
can see can see the connections
but if you have hundreds thousands like
tens of thousands of or millions of data
points nodes on the screen suddenly They
um you it's very inspiring.
It's like
impressive. It's like a galaxy. It's
beautiful. But what is what what any
meaning you get out of it? Um it's
challenging. So it's um like the the
visualization example I just show
earlier. um it's important because we we
get a sense of the difference between
different industry uh that serves as the
purpose. The next question is really is
like what is the um um specificities of
it? What's the individual things of it?
If we start driving down drilling down
and uh having too many elements on the
screen is actually become a problem. Uh
so for that reason um like I found it
really hard to thinking RDF. I think RDF
is like uh once we have a logical
reasoning using using machine to think
about to reason to to derive is great
but for me to think in RDF is really
really challenging. But same thing for
LPG is the same like uh like LPG the
data if you stop putting putting like a
gigabyte of data in there like I can't
think over it and so I have to uh so
that's really I feel like there's a I
need a strategy in in helps to to think
over the large amount of data and also I
think the graph what is the graph like
really
has a we need to uh think about the
difference between the different stage
of the graph like namely like for the
data capture how do you capture the
graph capture the data using the graph's
structure
also the very uh like uh reasoning and
the presentation uh the final final
stage presentation um is is to me it's
very different like uh with with with
the storage like the traditional form is
table and then you have the like JSON
document and then you have like the
graph is very efficient way of like
have a flexible way of capturing
information but still maintain
structure. Um I want to show you
example. See?
So,
this is a uh see if I can
So, I'm totally improvising here today
because we have small number of people.
just really feel free just help me ask
questions and uh u
to help drive this conversation
together. Uh so
this particular data set is a uh in in
the US um they have um um all the flight
information become public after two
weeks. Um so we we data out look at it.
So there's many many ways looking at
that data which is one of this is data
set I I used to supposed to be like
hands on step by step I think I'm just
going to skip it and show you guys what
what's possible what's the thinking
behind it
doing that is um using animation to uh
to display the information um now
the purpose for this is really to to to
see
>> if there any surprises is any pattern we
can discover. Um
just looking at the data is is is
challenging but looking at the looking
at the um this animation will reveal
some some interesting patterns.
So
the data it's um I want to quickly talk
about the the data. So the data is from
the data downloaded from from department
transportation has 119 columns. Uh if
you look at 119 columns uh there's a
large empty space right on the right.
It's it's very sparse and it turned out
each flight can be diverted uh diverted
and when when there's a diversion you
need a record. So, so you need to
reserve a set of columns to to uh to
record a diversion.
But sum has two. Now you have the second
column set. Sum has three. And in this
data set you have five. So basically if
the airplane gets diverted five times it
can be recorded. But if you somehow get
diverted six times too bad
that won't you cannot exist according to
this table. So this is really
interesting things like how we
structured information
determines what information can be
captured. Um and it actually comes back
to even deeper question about the
naming. Actually let me go back to your
slides and
like the naming of things is I found
that to be fascinating. Um the uh the
western philosophy from Greek time um
this Aristotle think uh the name is
focused on significant by convention
and it really believe there's a
substance
of underlying reality that exists
independ
I think really really crucial
um that
that first there's underlying reality
second there's name that we approximate
that we're trying to get as close to the
reality as possible
uh that really influence uh all the
developments science technical
development in the west
responsible for the the technology boom
that we see for the past last several
centuries is the the eastern the Chinese
that this all happens like two 2,600
years ago around the same time right so
the Chinese philosy says like if you can
name something if you name something you
get it wrong and uh it also further says
that uh nothing has a permanent u uh
like substance
uh you can only
literally you only have meaning when in
when it's in the interaction with other
things. So basically the context is
everything like when when the the naming
of things is not that uh crucial because
name the the essence always shifting but
the context is everything. So basically
the uh the the the Chinese philosophy
really thinking in graph
more less thinking in entities. And so I
just had a conversation with somebody
yesterday. We start talking about when
we put things in the graph format
sometimes not that important to have a
name for the relationship or the name
for the entity. Just the fact that
there's a connection, the patterns
already tells a lot about what's going
on. You may not be able to describe it,
but it's actually like a really um
telling. So hence I think you when when
we use graph visualization we have a lot
of those kind of um um perspective
information that we need to observe and
we need to reason over it rather than a
descriptive uh information. Yeah. So
that's something I I've been
experienced. This is also where I look
at the what kind of data format the data
structure to capture the data and that's
the um um that's like looking for from
the table format uh to the uh the JSON
format to do format to the like RDF
label property graph each one of them
has their special like applications some
special places that's really the right
data structure to
But each one of them has all also have
their uh limitations. So in essence
there's no uh easy way to know the right
way. There's no right way to capture
everything. Uh like table is extremely
easy to manage like all the
transactional stuff like putting the
table is so easy to manage to scale. Uh
like graph is challenging.
I know Ricky has a solution but I don't
I'm thinking about it. graph you
changing one bit information potentially
you change changing a lot of cascading
connections but the graph is amazing for
analytics
uh label probably like RDF in certain uh
like when you have a very clearly
defined domain it's amazing because it's
it's clearly uh it's the information is
is coded in a way that you can reason
with the
But then if you're in a high dynamic
situation and everything
shifts, the devolution shifts, uh you
have trouble. Like um we um I found out
that uh between Japan, Japanese culture
and American culture,
when does the green become blue is
different.
So by coding something by the color as
green or blue and reason on top of it uh
if you don't attach the cultural
background you may potentially be in
trouble.
And so that's kind of things that's like
um how much a uh a symbolic coding can
code the reality um is very depends on
the context. Like if you can accept your
boundaries it may work very well but
anytime the you need to uh qualify
what's the boundary of the of the
application where I'm coding it. Yeah.
So back to this data set. Um
here's all the columns I found in the in
the data set. And uh you have the date
information, you have airline
information, flight number and you have
original uh where is come from airport
and destination
uh and uh you have the departure
information.
So when when I look at it, I realize
like oh wow the the airplane the flight
is really not as simple as I thought.
And that's actually the thing with
everything I did with the data is like
once you look into data this always
things you don't expect the more
information more data you need to
capture and not even talking about edge
cases when you start talking edge cases
that's um suddenly the the the thing you
need to consider is
ex exploding um arrival information um
cancel and delay information
um and then diversion diversion one two
three I just skip it so
this information um so on the right it's
trying to group them into like in the
graph format because what one one
examp one thing immediately jumps out is
uh If you model as a graph right now,
you can actually test have as many
diversion as possible. It doesn't matter
anymore like how many diversion you
have. So so really um when you we break
this the table down into graph format as
a relationship the the constraint of
what information can capture um is
loosened. This is like a big improvement
of the graph. Yeah, that's um I what I
really really appreciate and um now
let's load the data in the uh database.
So
so I actually
in the GitHub I prepared this like uh
data set. So if you guys interested you
can make work later I can just
demonstrate how it works today.
So I I used used new 4J for this
exercise. uh using new forj like a
data database like browser new browser
just uh create a project you guys all
use new browser right
you use the yeah yeah okay so I don't
even go over that
great yeah so
short it's just like I have some scripts
in how to load this data sets can if
you're interested you can look at that
later um basically just like here I just
modeled the data into uh airport
um originally you have
the you have origin and destination so
normalize the name
uh airline [clears throat]
and flight information
for this exercise. I just ignore the um
diversions
[clears throat]
and and
you can use so what I what I want to
demonstrate here first is um so so when
I look at the how we work with the graph
data perform an analysis investigations
I notice there's a couple different
patterns uh one pattern I call a graph
walk
graph walk is you start with some place
um like a name, a address, an entity and
you start looking for what are the
connected things. So this is the most
similar to how we think and it's like we
think by like even how we remember
things, how we memorize things, we
memorize things by association. So we
often think from one place go to the
next go to the next start building off a
a map of this. So I found that that
approach is like in the a lot of
investigation uh use cases. I see the
investigators analysts they use this
most often. Um now with the um
with the new 4J browser you you could
write this type of query to pull out the
specific informations. Uh um but in the
application uh that
go into the production for the
enterprise it's more convenient to
building search and then expand. So I
call that search expand is the uh like
fundamental elements for for for graph
walk. Yeah. And so it seems
I just want to have a quick like
introduction. So I'm just going to use
use graphics are to to illustrate this.
Um so
let me just like uh clean up the let's
see let me put this
Okay.
So
in the data we created we have those
categories being created like aircraft,
airport,
such and such. Um
[clears throat]
to make it easy to search. Um so
basically uh did I just one second
I think I've got the
Yeah, that's the
So, uh let me go back a little bit. So,
here's in the uh in the uh read in the
data set I have this.
So basically you create a project
because I'm I'm running the new database
on the on the local host. So just give a
credential. I'm asking to connect the
data directly to the database.
So so the data does not go through the
internet. There's one um practical
reason is because the when you're
running Neo4j locally um it's HTTP HTTP
uh connection uh however any web app
that is over internet HTTPS
um you won't be able to talk to another
database on the another server using
HTTP but locally you can so
that's why we asked the connection to
just a fast directly to the to the local
database. Um so
once you you uh so here's the uh this
the three entities like categories uh
the loading script created and u here
are all the relationship I created but
to to to perform um the the graph walk
so the easiest way I do is I first I
create index so basically I say here
like a I add uh the area code city to
the index. And once we have indexed um I
can just quickly say hey let me search
for uh SF
since I come from San Francisco that
let's
once we have the just expand from here.
Yeah, we can see uh let's see let's see
which other cities is connected and
and maybe we can look at the secondary
connection. Let's connect them all to
the
[clears throat]
spend.
Oh, that's a lot.
So
I think I made a a
choice wrong choice because San
Francisco is a hub. So when San
Francisco system go to the other hub
then suddenly you have a the graph
become very dense. And this graph is
actually I think also called skillfree
network because if you look at the
distribution of the number of
connections it's it's a logarithm um
change thing. So
let me go back to it the stuff on SFO.
Let me just finding a just look at the
first
first line display and then maybe do a
uh perform a layout uh let's see a tree
layout or circular layout.
So to just like uh make information
easier to digest or I can put on the
graph look at all the cities that
connected from has a direct flight from
San Francisco. Uh so this is really I I
I found that this kind of way of working
with data is more um hands-on
explorative deep on the information and
then like maybe I can see hey uh from
this city over here uh that's Spokam
what others cities has
connected to. So you can just like uh
step by step explore. So this is manual
investigation process uh which I found
it to be uh happens very often in in the
investigation workflow. The other
process is where you actually have a
idea about I I want to pull certain a
subgraph I want to pull certain
information out and then I want to find
a way to visualize the information uh in
the most effective way. Um
so um
with um with the data loaded in the in
the graph database where of course you
can start to run a lot of graph
algorithms. Uh so in this case what I
what I did is like uh uh
I added some statistical calculations of
of the the of the airports. Uh now like
for each airport look at the uh how many
arrivals it has
how many departures it has. Uh by the
way I only know single day for for this
purpose and the data set I have on the
on the on the GitHub is about one month
data but it's pretty big and if you
start doing one one year data you can
start doing like a seasonal uh analysis
trend analysis but even for one day uh
for a uh like this like illustration
purpose is more than sufficient
and you can look at um uh delays like
you can look at is there any association
with the uh how busy the airport is with
how long the delay is which airport has
abnormally high
like delay times. Yeah. So all all a lot
realize that graph um there's problem
definitely graph answer but there's a
lot of problems is really in the
traditional like BI or analytics realm
that the the graph platform should also
be able to answer and so
once we have those informations in uh
let me let me just pull all the uh
graph data all the air point out let's
see
okay let's get rid of the connections
just look at the airport itself
so here are all the airports uh airports
in the US and in in this data set and if
you look at the properties that we have
and uh there's uh many properties like
uh the uh delay uh arrival flight delay
uh departure flight delay that's average
computer for each city and then I have
some like between closeness uh vector um
like centrality
page rank and the total total number
arrival total number departure. So, so a
lot of so a lot of attributes here is
calculated on the graph and using the
graph calculation. Now then how we how
we visualize it, how we make sense of it
is um
those are dimensional data. So we
probably just want to uh using a uh
dimensional visualiz.
So that's something very easy to do with
any Python or JS code here. It just
makes it uh so let's look at um let's
say between
uh closeness and page.
That's interesting.
So by the way this I haven't done that
before. really just my first time just
like uh look at the data and with you
guys to see what we can what we can see.
Um so
you see there's some nodes with very
highness. Uh let me let me see if I can
could see the
oh DFW. Where's DFW?
>> Oh yeah, Dallas sport. Yeah. um
that one has like a
very high in all three matrix. So this
this this this is a very important
airport. If this airport somehow if
there's like a hurricane or something
happens over there, it's going to affect
a lot of flight and the second one is
Denver. Uh but what's interesting is
like uh most of this like uh airports
even they have a high closeness
but between us is pretty low meaning
there's a few hugs that really like
there I I think what's what's
interesting airlines this something I
realized is um
there's a big flight connecting major
cities and then there's a lot of this
like spikes like connect to smaller
cities. [clears throat] So
the the rod between big cities become
important like spies.
This is really like uh illustrated like
that
what happened in the in the in the road
design of of of the industry.
So next let's look at um um
let's look at let's see
look look uh total arrival
total departure
versus uh average arrival delay.
So that's also interesting. uh you see a
almost perfect um connection well total
arrival to departure they are the same
because when you have arrival you need
to go back so it's no surprise here um
so with you look at this look at the um
correlation between um
like average delay
uh and u so that that's interesting that
it means like uh the okay let's look
from here
it the uh the number of uh flights the
how busy the airport is is there's not a
direct correlation with the with the
delay um so
and in fact there's a few
this is one airport that's particularly
bad SMS see which one is it
Santa Maria Yeah, maybe most like it has
a bad day.
Once we look at the over the time, we
might see some different patterns. Um,
but this is one one important thing to
to to
like look at the data like really even
though our data is kept in the graph but
very often we really want to look at
data as dimensional as well. Yeah.
>> Question. How hard can [clears throat]
this over time because in America
I know there are many more direct
>> a lot of things change really
interesting to me just as travel
>> to see this time
>> well it's here is pretty easy because um
there's a couple way to do that one is
like I just load every data data as as
as a note and then I can apply a filter
to to filter on the time that you can
when I filter immediately can see how
things jump. The other thing is um uh
this is one another concept is called
like data driven data mapping
visualization.
So if you have a like here it's a data
mapping meaning if I change the property
on on this node it's going to shove in
the in the position. So, so we through a
so through a we can just change the
numbers or even live change the numbers
and you will see things animates over
the time.
So um one of the thing I noticed is like
the importance is of a change in
perspective.
Here we look at the one perspective of
uh like a departure and um and a delay
but we maybe we want to like for example
let's say here um if I go to shift into
the users
let's see I'm just going to let it start
rotating slowly and
shifting between two different
perspective
So this technique is actually quite
useful in many situations. Um especially
in highdimensional data like um very
often we because what we can visualize
is is two-dimensional
information. two dimension information.
Let's say if you if you add the color,
shape, um size
plus two dimension, you have roughly
five dimension information can be coded
visually at the same time. Um be able to
have added third dimension is very
helpful because uh one thing like adding
a dimension is not 1 + 1= to two. is is
really um it's like the volume the area
we can compare. So be able to have a
third additional dimension to visualize
information often is very very helpful
uh in in gaining the insight. We
actually have a I actually have a video
since we have a
random talk. I just going to show you
guys things I have done before like
information. Okay. I show sure what is
uh let me see actually it's in the
let me see
is that one
yeah that's a video
I was
This is example of
just one second. Uh let me change the
sharing.
This is not exactly graph visualization
but it's more like a high dimensional
visualization. So this is a uh
measurement so called flow seytometry.
really uh you take the blood cell from
the
blood samples. You send each blood cells
through a uh um instrument to measure
about between 20 to 45 primeters.
And then you can look at this like high
dimension information. We're trying to
figure out like uh whether um the
patient has cancer or what kind of
cancer the patient is patient has. And
to look through this those like uh high
dimension informations it literally
takes a expert doctor four hours at
least to compare many many two
dimensional
plots to to identify uh what actually
happened what actually uh
like plaster of the blood cells uh that
indicating of the cancer And so what we
did is um we uh so this is a VR
application. We really represent each
cells as a node in the space and and
also
um there's a there's a two connected 3D
3D scatter plot. So essentially you look
at the six dimension spatially uh at one
time and that the ability to select a
group and look at the all the splitting
in the other presentations
that dynamically change your selections
change the parameters that you use
present [clears throat]
that literally help them to identify the
like important clusters down to 10 to 15
And uh so there was the example that the
the person who just is talking about he
was in London here at a gas guys
hospital just across the cross river. So
they gave him a case that hey this case
would took us a week. What you what can
you find in in 15 minutes? He figured
out, hey, look, this is this is class
cluster B cells indicating that the
person has this um cancer cells. And
this ability to identify that clustering
is really because he he was able to look
at the sixdimensional information all at
once without be able like does not need
to shift context because if you look
from the a static two dimensional
scatter shifting to another shifting
there's a lot of contextual shift that
really slows you down be able to see
them in one place it's things everything
becomes so much easier to digest
That's really the the power of
visualization, right?
That makes so much easier to gain what's
to see see into data, see what's what's
what's in there. Um,
which one is that?
So,
now I just want to show you one more
thing is with this example. And um
here we have all the airports like
loaded with on the map.
Uh
we want to see a uh [clears throat]
so this is where my thinking is uh the
graphi.
Uh with a graph we can analyze a lot of
graph specific questions
but in application very often you have a
lot of traditional statistic question
you need to answer. Um so a uh a uh
connected uh uh charts uh which is a
standard like uh chart today is really
easy to make with D3 with all the a lot
of framework allow you to make this but
unify with the unify the dashboard with
the graph exploration tools is very
handy very powerful like especially if
you can make things interactive like for
example Like I look at this dot I can
immediately
drive into the visualization to to see
what's going on like
it tells you like so
that that kind of connectivity of uh of
like statistical visualization
and graph visualization. is is very
handy which I think uh is the future of
the like a lot of graph analytics.
So,
so from my own experience, I feel like
um um there's a visualization for
communicating u purpose, presenting,
communicating, but there's also
visualization for the for the reason of
uh uh discovery analysis and they have
very different requirements. Uh one of
the thing is
like how do you go from the data in the
management layer to the data in the
communication layer. Data in the
management layer has a different
requirement like it requires the data
easy to be captured requires that you
can you can capture the truth of the
data like the nuance of the data and u
have enough flexibility to capture
different scenario different situations
and so the data needs to be uh verbals
and needs to be for example one one
example is like emails like if If you
want to capture the transaction of
emails, then like if you if you just
capture
person A, person B as nodes and you you
encode the email interactivity as the
edge, now you have a problem, right? If
you have to forward email, how do you
code that?
uh if you if you have to like describe
like a reply email uh or the reply to
the email which emails the emails on the
edge uh it's very difficult to to to
code all those informations. So if you
if you encode each email exchange has
separate node then you can apply the
email not being received the email being
forwarded email being replied email
being deleted. So, so a lot of
information can be can can be can be
captured. So, this is where uh but but
the same thing in the visualization
layer. If you have a visualization of
two people with a thousand email
exchange, you know, have a thousand
email notes and two people that's very
hard very difficult to to uh to to
reason to think because um as as I said
earlier, we can only think about seven
elements at the same time. So when we
when we when we visualize information uh
we need to really simplify the graph as
much as possible to support thinking
make it easy for our brain to digest to
think.
Now that really have a present a unique
challenge is how do you go from data
when it's in the data capture layer it's
a to the communication layer there's a
big gaps needs to be covered. Um now
with the with the common visualization
technique we have today is you have the
data in the database and you send a
query pull the data out and visualize
it. uh that is also of the problem
because um
um you stuck with the schema you build
in the database.
So really um what I found out is
you really have a um you need to have a
system to evolve the schema from where
it is in the uh in the data management
layer data storage layer to the data
communication layer and that schema
like uh evolving is the key to the
analytic workflow. Um this is something
I felt is it's a a void in the all the
graph analytic platforms. It's like how
do you you could you could use a query
to build a a new graph
but it's really not easy to do and and
not easy to think about how you do that
and
for that reason by the way do you know
what time is med
>> 25 minutes good so
this is where
uh
I came up with this uh framework of
called visual catalyst. Uh so it really
to just to think about how we can mutate
the graph data
um
to perform the uh the schema mutation
data trans transformation
uh visually without the need to to
result to the coding. And so so I came
up with a few common patterns. One is
the the map. Map is in the map reduce
map is you you have a function. You take
a set of input you get output. Uh the
second one is aggregate.
Aggregate is really a reduced function.
Basically you query all your neighbors
to look at properties or query all the
edges you connected to. Look at all prop
properties come back uh with a uh a
number or property. Um link essentially
is a link prediction inference or like
you give a condition to see whether two
entities should be connected and give a
give a link.
um
extract is a remodeling technique right
let's say in this group of people if
there's something common you can pull
that out
now you make in this particular case I
use game of throne data set example so
here's all the characters in game of
throne they all belong to house man so
you can you can represent that as a
dimension information where which house
they belong to. You guys are watching
Game of Thrones, right?
>> No. Good for you. Yeah.
>> I just watched Breaking Bad.
>> Breaking Bad.
>> Yeah. Game story is very bloody like a
lot of killings, a lot of things going
on there. So extremely popular the TV
series. So, so you can look at the house
like Lannister as a um dimensional
things which is like a a property but
you can also look at the graph
perspective you have this is house those
character belong to this house but that
transformation give you a uh flexibility
of
when you record the data originally
right you don't really have to
pull that out model that as a separate
entity
uh
un unless we need it. So that give you
flexibility in when you record the data
um knowing that you can establish that
graph later uh that allow you to record
data in the most simple way. So that's
one. Yeah, go ahead. So the things that
you now describe visual language that's
basically
an infer schema on the Right. You know
that's part of it. It would seem
already. Yes, we can do that.
>> Yeah,
>> I was going to ask architecturally this
seems like a problem.
It's not
just an
absolutely absolutely so
like in the enterprise like management
you deal with data automatically. So you
once you establish those layers you get
automatically here is more
establishing set operators so you can
work with any data set like on demand
but the concept is the same it's like
you can leave your data in the original
forms simple graph forms knowing that it
can be morphed into a form that you need
to ask a question because Really whether
this needs to be a no or needs to be
property depends on what question you
you're trying to ask.
Unfortunately, the question you try to
ask is often not clear at the beginning
when you collect all the data. You don't
really know what exactly question you
want to ask. So you're trying to perfect
your schema
uh in early stage is challenging.
You need a you want to build a schema
that can support different kind of
questions but at a time you don't even
know you fully understand your questions
that's challenging
and uh the last one is a shortcut
shortcut example of like early example
use email as example like two people has
a thousand emails and the shortcut is
where the company translating to hey
those two people just had email exchange
like reading chip.
Um now what that what that what that
does is really help you to simplify the
graph conceptually because um like it's
important if we want to know whether
email gets forwarded or deleted the
level but in the let's for example if
you want to analyze the culture of the
company look at the sharing uh patterns
you just need to know how people whether
the people has some sort of interactions
or how many how any interaction they
have in this case simply have edge exist
between two two two people is sufficient
that's so the last is better um and um
in the um um I can quickly demonstrate
how can you perform this like uh
visually uh let's see
let's see I
think I have a data set here. Yes, I do
have a data set here.
So here this is the original data set uh
which is the you have character name,
house name, character image and you also
have who killed who
how many other character people killed.
So
it's already a graph if you realize that
Q Q by is really it's reading shell but
we store that in the table format. So
now let's just uh not going to save it.
Let's just pull this into this window.
Um so so here we have a 38 87 characters
have been generated.
We happen to have a uh URL like if you
look at the any data you can see there's
a character image and that we can just
use as advertised a bit more visual.
Now let's do the first transformation.
Um let's see we want to
find find all the house the house name.
Okay, there we go. Uh,
so
>> I'm lazy. Just call in the house.
[clears throat]
>> Stupid question.
>> Yeah.
>> Category
just
>> category. Yes. So in LG L is category.
>> Yeah. Label. But I I prefer category. Um
I found like
label can be received.
Um this also has implication on how you
manage data. Label implies you have no
schema. It's just a label on things.
But I think in in the enterprise space
manage data schema is important.
category means you have a new set of
properties associated with that have
that expectation. So that's why uh we
use categories.
Yes. So
so now we have um find out like those
those characters that have have host
that they they belong to. So that's
[clears throat] one transit
transformation and then uh once you have
that you can do a calculation. Let's see
I I want to aggregate to house and agg
just just to see like do a do a do a
count
because like
number uh character.
So this can be easily done in
cypher or any quer language too. The
difference is when you have a operator
designing visually you can perform those
kind of calculations like without
breaking your flow.
So now now I have um
oh something is wrong.
I'm sorry.
See,
there you go.
I can start to see like the characters.
We can behave. uh let me
use use the size to represent uh how
many how
popular is is the house. So this is one
way of um looking at information. But
now for example we have established a
person in a house some other person is
also house we can we can infer they are
in the same house they so we can do
another transformation like um shortcut
using house pivot we can see like uh
that you pass of people who are
fellowship with each other uh with the
house. So this is example of how you
perform. At this point I can just drop
house just like now the other way to do
it is um
earlier we have see who killed the who
want to represent represent like
visually. So let's see go to link and
kill uh
kill the buy. So this will be Q
that immediately give you let's make it
look
let's see
like
the network of John if you watch
this person is and white water and uh
and so all the all the people's
area stock that came up. So this is
really a way of
transform how you represent the data uh
easily. So you can
you can think it while you work with the
data and simplify your graph
representations
for so this is where I feel like is
needed for a visualization called
purpose. So this is visualization to to
count information to just to to show the
information for this here is what what
you what you need is visualization for a
uh for that for the purpose of
performing analytics.
How many minutes do I have?
>> Uh about 10 more minutes.
>> 10 more minutes. [clears throat]
So this is um
the code uh to to perform like a few
like a visual transformations I just
described like if you use the
traditional just use coding it's very
elaborate
how you make it simp
But if you using visual operators and
it's very simple uh concept
and I want to just show one more example
and this is all like uh in the uh data
set there's a example called let's see
transaction
this transaction is modeled after some
global uh talk money uh flow transaction
around the globe. Yeah.
So uh you have the
CSV slight
to just a standard receiver date and
amount and
you can
using the same same technique as we did
before. I'm going to delete this. I'm
just gonna
drag and drop.
So now each row of the data is
represented as a a note in a space and
we can see what they are. There's a
month, there's a date, there's a who.
Now
obviously we can just like uh start to
we can color by the um standard
receiver or we can see uh use the uh
size amount
using a P scale to to show size the
transaction amount obviously
let's just make the size the uh
to this work
shifting uh like visual representations
between the size, the color, the shape
is very helpful in the visualization. Um
but what's more interesting is we know
this is a graph. How can we easily do
all of them? So let's perform a uh
extract. So we have sender in the data
set. So let's pull the sender out.
Send is a person. So like it's a person.
Uh so now it's like from
all the people who uh create transaction
init transaction and we can do the same
thing to uh get rid of
I should make a mistake here.
Yes, I made a mistake. Let me do it
again.
person from
name
as a person. The topology should be
named
Now we can look at the receivers
too.
So now we have money trans like a flow
of money network and and this network as
I said earlier you have between the
nodes you have a lot of transaction and
one look at the flow is only add the uh
use
then I can over the time
the transaction happens in this specific
network.
And this is very ination
that you can exam
look at the dynamic system of change.
We want to just have a uh
like a pool and who has transaction how
much happen. So in this case we want the
uh short like
transaction from to
uh so that will be
as transaction to simplify it. So and we
want to do the uh
total amount and uh also how many
session have amounted.
So now we have the new relation created
that is get rid of the old transaction
which give you a more concise uh map of
things. So the
so the fact that you can do this makes
reduce a lot of um overhead in the in
the data modeling for data storage here
because when you capture the data you
really focus on capturing the data to
preserve as much nuance as much like um
details as possible capture the truth
and what you know as you
as you start doing analysis you will be
able to uh simplify your schema to per
to like transform schema for the for the
analysis.
So here's one of [clears throat]
you have a you could just like
dynamically play through the
transaction. Here we actually when we
look at it we find out
there's people who is always standing
out there's a people who is always
receiving and there's couple in the
middle you can see a very tiny pattern
of transaction coming in goes out
somewhere somewhere in the middle
>> way we're just about time and we have a
short lunch break today so I want to
make sure we wrap up
>> yeah but if anybody has any one last
question we've got a one or two minutes.
>> Yeah.
>> Otherwise, yeah, let's just Oh, go
ahead.
>> Is it possible to see transactions?
>> Yeah.
Well, that's close to
>> Yeah,
interesting to see.
>> that is um I can see lots of different
way of visual
visualiz.
>> Yeah.
Yeah. So it's like there's some you can
detect loops in the in the
um and highlights
and also here we have something uh
there's starting time there's ending
time. So basically you know the two into
a starting point like who starts the
transaction then who is the mutual
receiver of that those transactions
>> like temporal do that
>> yeah
yeah
>> thanks you have
you start
goes out to the first neighbor, second
neighbor, third neighbor. You can see if
there something that somehow comes back.
That's one possibility you can let it
follow the direction.
>> Uh also just want to add
>> weakness thinking. So we can come into
you know layer layer by layer layer.
dependent situation can track
you know those the starting participant
entity then layers layers layers
eventually the final destinations
>> you're welcome thank you
>> thanks
thank you